[Musique]
irak janvier 2018 nous sommes à kara me
lèche un village chrétien dans le nord
du pays
ils n'ont pas détruit
détruit une
jusqu'en 2016 ce territoire était occupé
par l'état islamique
ici c'était plein de boue l'état
islamique à stocker toute la boue des
tunnels ici dans l'église sous ce
monastère une galerie de tunnels
vestiges de la stratégie militaire de
dèche
on peut constater vraiment le tous les
efforts qu'ils ont mis pendant pendant
deux ans d'occupation pour la bourse
pour se fortifier donc on peut imaginer
donc ça explique toutes les destructions
que l'on voit dans le village de g us
qui a probablement fait l'objet de
combats acharnés
non
parmi les décombres ces familles se
réunissent pour assister à l'office du
soir des parlementaires sont venus leur
témoigner le soutien de la france
car après avoir fui les persécutions les
chrétiens sont enfin de retour à karam
laich
à l'été 2014 ces images avaient fait le
tour du monde
mossoul abandonné par l'armée irakienne
l'état islamique envahi le nord du pays
où vivent de nombreuses minorités forcé
à l'exil les chrétiens abandonne tout et
se réfugie au kurdistan
trois ans plus tard le califat et vaincu
les familles chrétiennes regagnent
progressivement leur village mais dans
quel irak
vont-elles reconstruire leur vie emmené
par bruno retailleau
une délégation du sénat est venu
constater les conditions du retour des
chrétiens
le voyage débute à bagdad
passage obligé pour les sénateurs le
parti dawa c'est le numéro deux de
l'ambassade de france qui va les guider
dans leurs différents rendez vous dans
la capitale des ministres
le ministre du logement etc elle a été
reconduit dans l'appartement un sac à
main a indiqué que pat du masisi
sinistre et allemand
le déplacement se fait sous très haute
surveillance
des agents du gign assurent la sécurité
de la délégation
sept ans après le départ des américains
la capitale irakienne ressemblent
toujours un camp retranché
les sénateurs sont reçus par monseigneur
sakho le patriarche chaldéen de bagdad
les chaldéens sont catholiques
il dépend donc de l'autorité du pape ils
forment l'une des principales églises
chrétiennes en irak
si la présence des chrétiens dans la
région il est aussi ancienne que le
christianisme leur nombre baisse de
façon dramatique
un peu plus d'un million à la fin des
années 80 il serait aujourd'hui moins de
300 milles à peine 1 % de la population
[Musique]
la fuite des chrétiens hors d'irak s'est
accélérée à partir des années 90 et n'a
fait qu'empirer depuis la chute de
saddam hussein
certes beaucoup beaucoup souffert à
cause de notre religion
à cause de cette mentalité sectaire et à
seulement 10 da etc mais aussi d al
qaeda et des groupes fondamentalistes
qui pensent que les autres sont
infidèles et cetera les chrétiens ont un
espoir l'émergence d'une véritable
citoyenneté irakienne qui dépasseraient
les clivages religieux l'écrit telle
doit être ré l'identité nationale irak
et pour tout le monde
la religion c'est une chose personnelle
entre moi et dieu
cela n'entre pas dans la la société où
la politique si on voudrait faire un
progrès je crois c'est très important la
séparation de la religion et de l'état
sont très triste d'avoir vu beaucoup de
chrétiens quitter le pays mais on peut
les comprendre aussi parce que pour
beaucoup d'entre eux ne reviendront pas
c'est ce que cherchait d'ailleurs les
terroristes et des thaïs ta vie mais bon
en tout cas aujourd'hui à un nouvel
espoir celui de la reconstruction est
encore une fois cette reconstruction
elle voit passer par une vraie consulter
va passer par une communauté qu'on
connaît bien nous en france parce que
c'est notre tradition la citoyenneté
c'est à dire cette appartenance
nationale qui transcende le reste mais
l'appartenance nationale est une notion
fragile en irak pays d'abord divisé
entre musulmans chiites et sunnites
[Musique]
si les sunnites étaient favorisés sous
le régime de saddam hussein ils se sont
sentis opprimés par la majorité chiite
qui tient les rênes du pouvoir
depuis l'intervention américaine en 2003
[Musique]
salim al djoubouri le président du
parlement irakien
il reçoit ses homologues français
l'islam est religion d'état en irak si
aucune loi ne peut contrevenir aux
principes islamiques
la constitution garantit tout de même
l'égalité de toutes les communautés les
sénateurs sorte séduit de leur entretien
avec salim al joubouri
et on compte sur vous pour défendre des
droits de
[Musique]
différents
comme parlementaire nous avons pu parler
de l'avenir de l'irak de la fabrication
de la loi de cette réconciliation
nationale que faire des gens qui ont
collaboré avec des shs des irakiens mais
aussi des français des étrangers et il
est sunnite lui même mais sa vision est
une vision moderne je trouvais une
vision très pacifié entre les
communautés de l'irak
mais en attendant les chrétiens irakiens
se tourner vers la communauté
internationale pour qu'elle protège leur
présence dans le pays
j'ai bien compris que il était important
pour eux que le gouvernement irakien à
qui rien n'échappe sache que de
l'étranger des parlementaires mais aussi
des associations est d'aider des
milliers de gens s'intéressent à ce qui
se passe ici est donc qu'il ya derrière
finalement il ya une vraie force et que
ça oblige le gouvernement et les
décideurs à tenir compte de la présence
des chrétiens en irak
direction le nord et la plaine de ninive
à la rencontre des populations
chrétiennes
sur la route entre erbil et mossoul
les forces kurdes contrôle unique
checkpoint ouvert ses positions que les
peshmergas ont gagné contre edf ont
récemment fait l'objet de combats avec
l'armée irakienne baghdad n'entend pas
laisser les kurdes occuper ces
territoires
alors ici nous sommes au dernier
checkpoint kurdes
avant d'entrer dans la zone irakiennes
au checkpoint de razr est donc il ya un
grand tas de terre là qui bloquent la
route et du coup on attend que des
bulldozer passe pour dégager la route
pour que toute la colonne de camions
puissent passer la la ça c'est tous les
convois qui vont vers me saoule
voilà pour les activités du matin la
voie est enfin dégager le convoi se
remet en route à 30 km de mossoul
voici qaraqosh la grande ville
chrétienne de la plaine
[Musique]
à
c'est le dimanche de l'épiphanie
[Musique]
ces familles sont catholiques de rite
syriaque l'autre grandes églises
chrétiennes présentes en irak
la messe est chanté en araméen la langue
du christ
mais le notre père se récite en arabe
et
en 2014 face à l'arrivée de drèches
qaraqosh la chrétienne s'était vidée de
ses cinquante mille habitants
[Musique]
depuis sa libération en octobre 2016
près de la moitié d'entre eux est revenu
mais l'avenir reste incertain
[Musique]
la vie a de toute façon toujours été
difficile pour nous maintenant beaucoup
d'entre nous sont revenus bien sûr nous
sommes heureux la vie n'est plus la même
tout ce qu'on veut c'est la sécurité et
la stabilité
petros moche et l'évêque de qaraqosh est
de mossoul
après la chute du califat il a été l'un
des premiers à rentrer à qaraqosh afin
d'encourager ses fidèles à revenir au
début il avait beaucoup de méfiance
parce que bas avec les voisins tout ça
appuie lorsque l'on vit aussi leur
maison était surtout brillé ça les a
choqué beaucoup vraiment mais il faut
qu'ils sont rentrés maintenant et que la
vie commence à prendre un peu dans le
domaine des coatings moment de la
journée et surtout avec les pieds de
nouvelles et de publier deux mois
je vois que les gens bas de plus en plus
ce sont les se montrent qu'ils veulent
vraiment s'attacher à laruns a lâché
continuer de vivre ici pour donner le
témoignage risque qu'ont toujours les
cohabitants la confiance va rentrer
qu'on pourra continuer de vivre aussi
bien avec les sunnites et eve du shabak
avec cai
alors tous les gens qui sont autour de
nous
[Musique]
pendant la période d'occupation par
l'état islamique les familles de
qaraqosh s'étaient réfugiées au
kurdistan
leur retour s'est accélérée à l'été 2010
est quand les écoles ont rouvert et le
courant a été rétabli qaraqosh était
autrefois le poumon économique de la
plaine la vie reprend doucement ses
droits mais aucune famille n'a été
épargnée par la guerre
[Musique]
amir a perdu deux cousins dans une
attaque de l'état islamique
le 6 ou 2014 il s'est enfui avec sa
femme et ses trois enfants
[Musique]
sur la route on a été arrêté au
checkpoint les kurdes nous ont interdit
de continuer nous étions quinze
personnes dans ma voiture
ma famille avec une autre famille on
essaie d'être à deux cas la carrière et
je leur ai dit que je devais absolument
mettre ma famille en sécurité mais ils
ont refusé parce qu'on n'avait pas des
bons papiers pour la voiture célèbre
lapin blesle triana car on a voulu
continuer à pied
on est arrivé à erbil on nous a dit que
des ch et est maintenant à qaraqosh et
qu'on ne pouvait pas rentrer chez nous
[Musique]
mais les rues bordées de je côtoie après
un exil de trois ans à venir et sa
famille sont rentrés à qaraqosh en
septembre 2017
les gens ont encore peur
la situation n'est pas encore vraiment
sûr pour de nombreux chrétiens
le manque de sécurité reste le principal
obstacle au retour le spectre de dèche
est encore trop présent pour faire en
sorte que les déplacés puissent revenir
on voit bien que le facteur numéro un
c'est la sécurité quand vous avez une
région qui n'est pas en sécurité les
gens sont terrorisés
il faut dire que dash a été une
organisation extrêmement cruels ils ne
peuvent parvenir dont je pense que le
préalable du tout de toute façon c'est
la sécurité
c'est la paix
à qaraqosh ce sont des miliciens
chrétiens qui assure la sécurité devant
le vide laissé par l'état central
chaque communauté religieuse à sa propre
milice
dans ce contexte instable les chrétiens
de la plaine de ninive constate les
dégâts causés par des shs 1947 la plus
grande église dans le monde à ouvrir
autrefois la cathédrale de qaraqosh a
été saccagé et incendié les suggestions
c'est la sacristie la cour attenante
porte encore les marques de l'occupation
par les djihadistes cette cour a servi
de centre d'entraînement de tir de pâtir
les balles sont encore fichés dans le
mur de la petite église qui est abritée
derrière le mur dans lequel les
djihadistes tirait lajudie tout à
l'heure j'ai regardé j'ai essayé de la
puis non
s'entraînant dèche s'est appliqué à
éradiquer méthodiquement les symboles
chrétiens comme ici au monastère de mar
behnam haut lieu du christianisme en
irak et cdh qui a cassé les choses les
bas-reliefs du xiiie siècle ont été
démolies en a un à coups de burin et de
marteaux-piqueurs dans la cour plantée
d'oliviers les murs portent encore les
graffitis laissés par les djihadistes
pendant l'occupation le monastère
servait de siège de la police des moeurs
de l'état islamique pour la région c'est
ici que certaines sanctions coup de
fouet exécution était prononcée clamé le
texte il s'agit d'un extrait du livre
écrit par le père dominicain michael
najib qui de cette région là et qui
s'intitule sauver les livres et les
hommes voulais vous montrer ici le lieu
on les livres de la bibliothèque du
monastère ont été brûlés en forme
d'autodafé par les djihadistes de dèche
toutes ses statuts toutes ces figures
qui ont été détruites volontairement ces
livres qui était la transmission du
passé qui ont été brûlées sahara ça
rappelle des souvenirs les grands
autodafé de 2 34 35 ans en allemagne par
exemple ou au moment de l'acquisition
si les islamistes s'en sont pris aux
symboles chrétiens ils ont aussi détruit
des infrastructures et des équipements
publics
à l'image de ce dispensaire entièrement
saccagé vingt personnes dont trois
médecins généralistes travail est ici ce
qui est incroyable c'est cette
application méticuleuse à tout casser
tout détruire tout détruire je peux pas
m'empêcher de faire la comparaison entre
ce que font bon nombre de communes en
france à savoir des maisons de santé
il le sait que nous venons de visiter à
l'instant est une forme de deux maisons
de santé il voir dans l'état l'état dans
lequel elle a été mise elle a été
vandalisée c'est vraiment c'est purement
gratuite puisque on est censé soigner
des gens ici alors que tout le matériel
a été détruit et on va laisser les gens
face à l'heure face à leurs souffrances
par manque d'argent et par parme ou
stupidité humaine et pseudo religieuse
à quelques mètres de là pourtant la
reconstruction a déjà commencé ce centre
culturel est en pleine rénovation
il sera ouvert à toutes les communautés
sans distinction de religion c'est une
ong chrétienne l'oeuvre d'orient qui
finance l'opération
[Musique]
hu a recommencé à travailler avec les
enfants avec les jeunes et faire des
fêtes et ils ont aussi ajouté un
sinama et on va faire
pour les familles on va faire des
projections de films
dans toute la plaine de ninive
les besoins en reconstruction sont
immenses
[Musique]
on
devant l'absence de l'état c'est
l'église qui coordonne les efforts avec
le soutien des ong à qaraqosh le père
georges a mis sur pied un comité de
reconstruction
je pensais à paris
chaque maison détruite a été
photographiée et répertoriés c'est le
cas d'un oui notre 4l et ganassi service
municipal d'urbanisme
ici c'est le président à ce jour 1200
maisons ont été reconstruites qaraqosh a
presque regagner la moitié de la
population que cette ville a connu il ya
pratiquement 22 mille chrétiens qui sont
revenus
donc c'est déjà une belle victoire et
tout le monde s'accorde quand vous
parlez aux uns et aux autres pour dire
qu'ils ont été surpris de la rapidité
avec lesquelles ces gens sont revenus
c'est vrai il y en a encore beaucoup par
revenir c'est un lent travail mais
justement le travail de reconstruction
de ces maisons est quelque chose de
capital grâce au travail de
reconstruction
la communauté chrétienne de qaraqosh se
relève doucement mais une autre minorité
encore plus souffert de la cruauté de
l'état islamique les yézidis
[Musique]
le village de bachy cas et un de leurs
fiefs cette minorité kurdophone pratique
l'une des religions les plus anciennes
de la mésopotamie
les sénateurs sont venus rencontrer le
share et easy dit ryan les yézidis
serait autour de 400 milles en irak
douze mille d'entre eux ont été tués par
des 7000 sont toujours portées disparues
et environ 3000 femmes et adolescentes
seraient encore détenus comme esclaves
sexuelles devant l'ampleur du drame les
yézidis se sentent abandonnés par l'état
irakien le gouvernement de bagdad ne
nous aide pas la loi n'est pas la même
pour tous elle ne nous est pas favorable
il y a deux poids deux mesures il n'y a
pas de justice de la part de bagdad pour
les yézidis
à la différence des chrétiens que l'on
retrouve un peu partout dans le monde
les yézidis ont seuls ils sont
persécutés par bardèche ils sont ils ont
peu de considération de la part du
pouvoir central chiites et sunnites
n'ont pas forcément beaucoup d'égards
pour eux pour eux donc ils sont seuls et
essayer profondément dramatique
[Musique]
le voyage se termine au kurdistan là où
les minorités ont trouvé refuge devant
l'avancée de dèche
malgré la chute du califat tous ne sont
pas rentrés sur le club al sadd est
primordiale et sa maison à lui et à
mossoul
elle a été pillée par son voisin et son
ami à lui eric dans ce camp vivent
encore 400 famille chrétienne de mossoul
une ville très majoritairement sunnite
pour elle le retour est difficile à
envisager
je travaillais dans une école en 2011
on m'a demandé de porter le hidjab
continuer à travailler
une de mes collègues à refuser elle a dû
quitter l'école pour gagner ma vie j'ai
accepté de le porter pendant quelques
années
si maintenant je décidé de retourner à
mossoul non seulement je devrais porter
le hidjab mais mes filles aussi après la
libération de mossoul je suis retourné
voir mes collègues à l'université où je
travaillais avant j'ai été reçue très
froidement avec un regard différent
méprisant
des lieux il disait si nos maisons ont
été bombardés c'est à cause de vous les
chrétiens encore aujourd'hui les
chrétiens ne sont pas acceptés à mossoul
parce qu'on considère qu'ils sont du
côté des occidentaux et ce même après
dèche
ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est l'avenir
de mon enfant tous les jours tous les
jours il pleure et c'est la même chose
pour les autres
pour ces familles la mention de la
religion sur les documents officiels est
une source de peur et ça c'est la carte
d'identité c'est la carte d'identité
espère probablement certes le nay
ça c'est la religion c'est la deuxième
la première mention c'est quoi la
première mention donc ça c'est la
profession océans sur la profession et
la deuxième cela
et bien à la religion et la confession
chrétienne et on peut être tué parce
qu'il ya ça sûrement
on était parti avec des témoignages
assez fort et positif sur la
reconstruction on l'a vu d'ailleurs ce
soit sur le plan économique de l'habitat
des déclarations du gouvernement et un
certain nombre de déclarations qui nous
rendait assez optimiste et puis là
c'était un peu la douche froide
il ya peut-être par moments une
confusion entre l'état et la religion et
la responsabilité puis que jamais me
semble ne devoir être prises à bras le
corps par nous tous mais à commencer par
l'état irakien
ces familles de mossoul n'aspire
aujourd'hui qu'à une chose s'exiler en
occident mais l'exode des chrétiens
menace la diversité ethnique et
culturelle de l'irak
cette minorité chrétienne et est sans
doute une des seules à pouvoir faire le
pont entre les autres communautés c'est
la raison pour laquelle c'est important
que l puisse demeurer comme jeu sur les
autres minorités mais que cette minorité
chrétienne puisse demeurer ici d'abord
elle est là depuis le départ bien avant
d'ailleurs l'islam mais on se rend
compte qu'elle est capable de dialoguer
avec les turkmènes avec les shabaks avec
les cacaille les kurdes les sunnites les
chiites et c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important
[Musique]
une vraie citoyenneté peut-elle encore
émergé en irak
par delà les clivages et les divisions
au printemps 2010 8
les irakiens seront appelés aux urnes la
future majorité aura la charge de
poursuivre la réconciliation du pays
[Musique]